this anarchy theme will begin to build
because we are locked in an impossible
cultural bind between a completely
exhausted and materialistic Marxism and
a completely cancerous and and valued
dark kind of capitalism
neither of these systems is tolerable
actually and they only and each feeds
off the other as its reason for being
the problem has always been with Anarchy
that people as WC Fields said are no
damn good and I think that's where
psychedelics come in the pre zijn people
are no damn good is because they have no
sense of social responsibility and it is
the cultivation of this social sense of
social responsibility that will pave the
way for anarchy and it isn't social
responsibility as preached from the
pulpit it has to be from the guts it has
to be real social responsibility and
then lo and behold the withering away of
the state and all these highly unlikely
things will actually come into view but
it it will take almost a sub telepathic
or proto telepathic society for this to
happen
computer networking and that sort of
thing can provide the hardwiring for the
basic data you know the banking data the
statistical data the real unconscious of
the machine part
but it's human beings that are going to
make this leap to responsibility to
usher it in its the completion of this
program of obsession with the Neolithic
it's the completion of the program begun
by psychoanalysis and psychedelic drugs
and you know a number of people who
might not have thought they would end up
on the same side I mean it's the
completion of the program of the Hugh
Hefner and the feminists because it will
eventually it is it does have this
polymorphic sexual content but it also
is certainly a goddess but God is
realizing kind of socialism this thing I
said earlier about emotions emotions are
the carrier wave of a being and we and
we have been blind to this for a very
long time